EMPLOYEES TO UNWANTED
SEXUAL ADVANCES.
HE HAD ALREADY RESIGNED AS
FINANCE CHAIRMAN FOR THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
CIVIL RIGHTS ADVOCATES ASKING
FEDERAL OFFICIALS FOR RECORDS
ABOUT CITIZENSHIP CHECKS IN
MAINE.
THE LAW ALLOWS ACTIONS KNEW THE
BORDER BUT SOME ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT RACIAL PROFILING.
HERE IS MOLLY LINE.
>> U.S. CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PATROL AGENTS IN THE FAR NORTH
DO FAR MORE THAN KEEP WATCH OVER
THE COUNTRY’S FRIGID BORDER WITH
CANADA.
AT A BUS STATION IN BANGOR,
MAINE, WHERE PEOPLE OFTEN HOP
RIDES TO BIGGER CITIES, AGENTS
RECENTLY ASKED PASSENGERS THAT
THEY WERE U.S. CITIZENS.
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION OF MAINE FINDS A PRACTICE
TROUBLING.
>> NONE OF US WANT TO LIVE IN A
SOCIETY WHERE WE ARE
CONSISTENTLY BEING TOLD WE NEED
TO SHOW OUR PAPERS.
>> THOUGH THEY DECLINED A
REQUEST FOR INTERVIEW, U.S.
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL
OFFICIALS CONFIRM THEIR AGENTS
ROUTINELY ENGAGE IN OPERATIONS
AT THE TRANSPORTATION HUBS